[Music]
welcome to the stanford mba student
alumni panel for the south and southeast
i'm allison davis and we're just go
ahead and
meet our panel and i'm going to ask
our panelists to introduce themselves in
the order that's here on the screen
and tell us a little bit about you of
course the basics are
up here so feel free to share some other
things in your background and i'm also
going to ask you at the same time if you
would
talk about a memorable academic
experience you had at the gsb
could be a professor or class or study
trip
or a project that you did okay let's go
ahead and start with francisco
uh my name is francis rodriguez i grew
up in
um a place called stanton virginia which
is pretty close to the west virginia
border
um before i came to the gsb
i uh ran a think tank in austin texas
and it was some people from texas here
uh for about five years um and now i am
an nba 2
slave to graduate in 2021 you came with
a spouse i think
didn't you yes i i got married a couple
years ago and so i came in with an so
i'm happy to answer any questions about
that process
um in terms of memorable academic
experiences
um for me i mean and it could be the
fact that it's one of the first things i
did the gsb but
everyone's required to do some kind of
global
study experience here uh and there's a
couple of different ways that you can do
that but the way that i could do so was
through
something called a global seminar which
happens prior to actually arriving at
the gsb so it happens in um
i guess august or august or early
september or something signs
and i mean immediately upon arrive i did
mine in china
immediately upon arriving in china and
meeting my future classmates i mean i
was just totally blown away by
everyone i mean their humility their
honesty their intelligence their humor
everything and so
it was a really really great
introduction the gsb and remains one of
the best
i've ever taken so that's right thanks
francisco
let's move on to stephanie hi
everyone i'm stephanie uh originally
from odessa texas
uh you might know it from friday night
lights and
um yeah i spent uh most of my life in
texas i went to ut austin from undergrad
and then
shortly thereafter i went to the bain
office in dallas for three years
before i went to gsb um and then a
little bit in between i was in
working in asia for a couple months but
um yeah happy to be here and
uh speak to you guys in terms of an
academic experience that
was really memorable to me my last
quarter which
was remote because of covet obviously um
i took
one of my favorite classes which was
called lives of consequence
and it was just this really beautifully
structured class that allowed me to kind
of
take a step back and reflect on the two
years i had with gsb and think about
kind of what do i want to do with that
and what does my life look like moving
forward in a way that
is meaningful but also like makes me
happy
and i found that to be an incredibly
rewarding experience
thanks stephanie and david yeah good
afternoon good evening
everybody david landry i live here in
nashville tennessee
grew up in phoenix did investment
banking and was part of the corporate
strategy
team that filled netscape to aol way
back in the day
uh since business school i've been in
technology working for siebel and oracle
for a while
and i'm now been at salesforce almost
eight years
and for me if i think about one of the
most memorable
kind of classes and it's actually a
professor i know he's still there joel
peterson
and he taught real estate which i wasn't
particularly passionate about real
estate other than you know
it's curious a house and house
valuations but really on commercial real
estate but the thing that stuck
with me is just his values and
how he was an honest values-driven
family person and that had taken him far
in his career he honestly talked about
where he had to make some tough
decisions and for me
that was a big reason personally why i
didn't want to stay in investment
banking
and part of the reason i've moved to
nashville
is to raise a family and i have four
kids
uh and they absolutely just
lighten up my day and challenge me in
every single way so
for me that most i'll say memorable is
just the leadership courses he taught
and how he talked about his career with
values and that's really stuck with me
and uh tamara hi good evening everyone
i'm tamara mullings
i graduated the gsb in 2014.
i had already been married for about
five years to my husband
we're still married after the gsb um
and we came together and that was uh
that was definitely
a good experience i also studied
engineering in undergrad so i actually
had no very little business coursework
before coming to the gsb
um it was one of the reasons i applied
to business school
i have worked in um i think i just
counted four
different industries um i've worked in
consulting i've worked in energy i've
worked in consumer products and now i
work at an insurance company
so um i appreciate having
a versatile skill set and um
that i developed at the gsb to kind of
you know do whatever
is interesting or next in my career
i'm also a mother i wasn't a mother at
the gsb
but now i am i have uh i have two little
girls two and four
and a baby boy on the way
and so navigating navigating
um you know working and what does my
career now mean to me now
when i went to the gsb i wanted to be
you know a ceo
and so um it shifted a little bit when i
had my kids
memorable academic experience there were
two
i'm going to pick um the one that
touches my heart the most
you'll hear a lot probably today and
you've already read about
the course that we name we call
touchy-feely
um it's a you it's an amazing experience
but it can be really challenging and
grueling and you spend
so much time with people they get to
know a lot about you
and give you some challenging feedback
and a memorable experience is at the end
there's like 15 of us and we're in a
circle
and we each pull out our cell phones and
we pass our cell phone around the circle
and everyone can say something that they
learn from us or that they appreciate
about us
and um and just validating
you and so after such a grueling
experience it's really nice to have that
and it's a little memento that all of us
you know still have and can pull out and
listen to if we need some encouragement
okay and lk hello
everyone my name is lauren christine
pryzant
and i am from houston texas and
currently living in houston texas
i know there are a few houstonians and
texans on the call so that's really
exciting
i went to unc chapel hill for undergrad
where i actually studied business and
finance
and then prior to the gsb i worked in
early stage venture capital since the
gsb
i have started my own company to
help people succeed through innovative
professional development
and i offer executive coaching and
emerging leaders coaching
as well as working with companies to
train their employees and design really
impactful retreats and
off sites and my most memorable academic
experience was
a class called conversations and
management
and this class is all about the critical
conversations you'll have as a leader
and preparing for some of the most
difficult situations you'll ever face
we learned how to manage a crisis how to
fire someone with grace and with empathy
and how to react when everything goes
wrong
and i love that this class used a lot of
role play
so in every class we would go deep into
some of these vignettes
and we'd even hear from the protagonist
about
how things went what they did what they
would do
differently if they could go back in
time and
ultimately this has just proved
invaluable in my own life
as i've navigated some challenging
conversations of my own great
thank you i'm going to ask you all one
more question and then we're going to
switch to the audience questions
as some of you may know personal
leadership development is a big part of
the stanford
curriculum and we've got a wonderful
range
of um work experience on the panel so
i'm going to ask each of you if you
could talk about
how the gsb curriculum and experience
prepared you i know for example tamara's
work both
in large corporate settings as well as
her own venture
and lk just started a venture and david
i know has a very large team at
salesforce and
big corporate setting um and um i'm
actually going to ask stephanie maybe
i'll start with you stephanie
uh to talk about uh your experience as a
our book a leadership fellow
which is an optional experience that you
can
do as a second year and if you talk some
about that
and how it's and impacted your your
leadership style
yeah i would love to um so
like allison mentioned the arbuckle
leadership program is something that
not everyone does but you apply to um at
the end of your first year so that you
can serve
as a squad leader and a personal
leadership coach in your second year
and i would say that it was definitely
one of the most defining parts of the
gsb for me
there's an opportunity to learn and grow
as a leader not only
um as in like a group format which is
how i primarily spent
um the first half of second year i had a
squad of six or seven
mba ones that i led through a class
called leadership labs
and i think from that experience um
in particular one of the things i took
away as i thought about leadership
is just the value of diversity as we
think about
um you know making sure that different
thoughts and different personalities and
different ways of thinking are heard
and what does it look like as a leader
to make sure that you can enable
all of those different voices um
in that way so i found that to be an
incredibly valuable lesson for me as i
think about leadership
and then the second part of the program
that i thought was really impactful
was just a lot of dedicated time
learning about what it looks like to be
a good coach
and so i think stanford does a great job
of
not only talking about leadership as you
know i'm a leader i tell you what to do
it's more about being a good coach which
means enabling people on your team
to um kind of be their best selves
as well as like have them tap into their
own creativity and their resourcefulness
and what does it look like as a leader
to help
enable that um and so that was one of
probably the
the most important um lessons that i
learned out of the
the program that um i'm really excited
to take back with me when i go back to
bing
great thanks stephanie i'm actually
going to jump next to francisco because
francisco was actually
in the squad that uh stephanie coached
as an arbuckle fellow
and uh and francisco you know you ran
your own
venture before business schools so uh if
you could talk about
lead labs and that experience and maybe
also comment
on uh how it's affected your leadership
since you'd already
uh you know run run your own shop
yeah um i mean as you all probably
guessed and know
um there's a strong strain of
entrepreneurship at the gsb i mean
there's tons of people who either
started their own
companies or firms prior to come here
and then tons that start afterwards or
during
um and i was one of those people who
started one beforehand
and i think that one thing that i
recognize coming to the gsb is there's a
large gap in my own leadership capacity
and the fact that
i as i'm sure many of you can can
empathize with or experience yourselves
really really heads down and working on
what i was doing
and as a result i think that my
leadership
style was more reactive than anything
else and such that
as opposed to being proactive with my
employees and being overly communicative
and and going on my way to be to be an
empathetic
kind person i instead just mostly did
things off the cuff which didn't really
work out what leadership labs allowed me
to do and
and what stephanie really helped
facilitate was just
more concerted reflection on both how i
communicate with people how people react
to my style of communication
and it's generally how you perform with
groups of people an interpersonal
dynamic basis and so just an incredible
opportunity
kind of set aside time every single week
to meet with a group of people who you
become incredibly close with and
connected to including
your squad leader to just receive
feedback on
new ways that you want to try to
communicate with people new ways that
you want to try being a leader
or stepping back or stepping forward in
a conversation
anything that you think would be
interesting from experimenting
with your own method of engaging with
the world around you so it's really
really useful
program and one that i look fondly back
on quite a bit
great thank you i'm going to continue
with this thread
with lead labs and move over to david
the leadership labs actually culminates
in an all-day simulation called the
executive challenge where you get to put
some of these school uh skills into
practice in
uh situations uh usually board room
situations with
um alumni who are who are role playing
and david's been a long time
judge at the executive challenge so
david i'm going to have you talk about
that experience from that point of view
but then i do also want you to comment
on
how the gsb has prepared you for you
know a
career especially in a large corporate
setting with a very large team
yeah thank you allison i think these
topics may actually come a bit together
and so as far as the executive challenge
it's really interesting because the
students are given a case without a lot
of time
which is very real life and there
they need to prepare to go deliver it to
a board of directors
and what you'll find quickly is the
right answer
is not going to get you consensus
there isn't necessarily a right answer
or a consensus answer but what you have
to do is really
learn and you have to listen you have to
empathize with people as you think about
what might make up a board
what if it's a family-run business the
insiders versus the outsiders
what's the role you know we've got
someone here from from bain
what's the role of a consultant how much
power do they really wield in this
company or not
and it varies and they don't give you
all the information so
part of the challenge and i think
stanford prepares you really well for
this
and quite frankly challenges you it's
why it's called the executive challenge
is to work through the dynamics and
as a leader your job is to control the
meeting
and to drive the company forward right
it's not coming up with the perfect
answer it's not doing this it's not
doing that it's not taking another six
months to decide
you've got six minutes to try and get
consensus and so
it challenges people but as much as it's
a challenge it's also great to be a
coach
and sit back and tell people what worked
what didn't work
what resonated with you or when you felt
alienated
or if the students think someone has
more power or they were led to believe
someone has more power and someone else
really does they might alienate someone
or ignore their comments like not
intentionally but
again time there's time pressure so it
gives you an opportunity to share that
feedback
being in role of this is how i felt or
how i reacted
not just in the case but as someone
that's on your board of directors
fast forwarding to your other question
around how did the gsb
prepare me right um it did in so many
ways
but one of the ways it taught me
was leaning into personal uncomfortable
conversations
whether it's touchy-feely or high-impact
leadership or i know they have different
names
but you think about it um this year not
just with the pandemic and talking to
people about
hey what's your work from home situation
tamara has
what is it two kids a third on the way
well guess what
if there isn't daycare that could put
some strains
on what's going on with her and her
ability and her hours and her
availability
um you know i hate to say it but the
murders of george floyd brianna taylor
ahmad arbory i have some
african-american people on my team
and yes a lot of people checked out and
reached in but how do you create a space
where people are comfortable bringing
their authentic selves
and how do you create that level of
vulnerability i know brene brown talks a
lot about
vulnerability as a leadership trait but
classes
at the gsb and even the gsb experience
challenge you to lean into it
going into the gsb particularly you know
having done banking first it was always
about hard charging and being right
and being smart and being working harder
guess what that's not what's going to
win the gsb challenger win
in a long term repeated game of life and
leadership
and it's coupling some of the things
that got you
to the gsb taking that
level of introspection to learn and be
willing to lean into some of these hard
conversations
recognizing you're gonna stumble a
couple of times and that's okay but
listen internalize and try and get
better and that's
what's going to set you up for greater
success
this year unlike any in my career has
had again
the health conversations that we've
never had the race conversations that
we've never had
and it's teeing up or it's been heavily
influenced by
the great learnings at some of the
sessions workshops
experiences at the gsb to really lean in
and be uncomfortable
and be comfortable enough to say i don't
know and i'm uncomfortable
and for me that was invaluable and it
really showed me that
leaning in to yourself and showing
vulnerability
is a strength to build a team
instead of showing weakness to make your
team think you're weak
great thank you uh tamara i'd love to
have you comment on leadership
in you know you've been in a large
corporate setting
you've been on your own venture at true
glory and
if you could talk about the different
leadership
attributes that you developed to deal
with those different settings
absolutely thank you i um
i mean the type of leader that you are
this is what i learned at the gsb
um you know there's like a true self
that you have that you should bring
to every you know company every job that
you have
but obviously you know what else we
learn at the gsb is that you have a
you have a toolbox with a diversity of
tools and skills and that's what you're
building
at the gsp that you bring out when you
need them so
um small company large company um you
know the same i worked at
the largest company i worked it was
probably ibm um
that's you know i actually had that job
before the gsb
the smallest company is the one that
allison just referred to called true
glory
i um some friends of mine who i met
when i went to stanford um invested in
this business
and asked me to to run it and there was
you know only 10 employees
so a very different experience i could
use all the skills that i learned
at the at the gsb but um really
that that job was the toughest
because i had some very difficult
relationships
conversations situations challenges
with my investors and um i think at
larger companies sometimes the way that
you
kind of manage up or partner is
you know you may defer a lot you may
you know anticipate what they want and
kind of serve
but you know when you're responsible for
helping a company
grow um and they've brought you
on to you know fix
things transform things show them where
their blind spots are
you know like david said you have to
like really lean into those
those conversations and it was really
uncomfortable i had never had experience
like that
before business school
but everything that i learned in classes
like interpersonal dynamics
and you know other leadership classes
management classes those comp those
those classes that
that simulate very difficult
conversations
came into play to really unwind some you
know
sticky dynamics when we you know
disagree
or when we have just kind of personal
challenges between this that are getting
in the way of
of growing the business um and and
i i wouldn't say you need those skills
more at us
at a smaller company because now i'm at
a very large company i'm at
at metlife the insurance company um
and um you know i think maybe it's it's
a it's more of a function of like
how you progress in your career and
sometimes
things just get more challenging more
sticky and you just need
more experience more skill
and that kind of you know journey
started for me or really took off that
transformation of the gsb
right and okay um how about talking
about
same question but maybe in the context
of you
launching your own venture right out of
the gsp
sure gsb taught me so many
different things that i've been able to
use in creating my own company
and i just think back to all of the
incredible entrepreneurs that came to
guest's lecture
in our classes i think i lost count of
how many incredible people
i met and were generous enough to share
their time
and really speak truthfully with us
about how hard it is
to start your own company whether it's
something small
or whether it grows like a rocket ship
you're gonna come in
into a lot of challenges interpersonal
challenges team building challenges all
sorts of things
and so being able to rely on
what i've learned at the gsb and then
also the network that i gained has been
invaluable i have really leaned
on my classmates as i've started my new
venture and they've been incredibly
supportive
and it's just great to have that network
of people you can turn to
when you are facing a difficult time and
you can talk it through with them
great all right thanks everybody so
we're going to switch
to audience questions and looks like
we've got quite a few already
uh feel free to submit them in the q a
box and again you can
upload them uh so let's see
we've got like a five part question here
with the most votes
um not sure we can get to all of these
but how about
um uh answering
um oh let's see
um
what the culture is like and i'm not
going to have every single person
answer every single question but
francisco i think i'll toss that to you
to begin with since you're
currently a student there um how you
describe the culture
yeah i've actually had this conversation
a lot with over the past several months
because
of you know the new round of admins
coming in and getting contact with them
i think that one thing that i have
really grown to appreciate about the
culture of the gsb that is a function
of the great people at emissions i'm
sure is one the really small class sizes
and two the fact that i think unlike
other programs maybe across the country
or across the world
the gsb despite the fact that i think it
attracts really really top-tier talent
and the class sizes are small
still maintained a level of immense
support for one another as opposed to
competition uh
and so the result is that you can openly
talk about
ideas and ventures you could study with
people for classes and there is i truly
have never
experienced some level of like again
toxic competition that may pervade other
schools that
you have that is totally absent here the
result being is that
um i think that people are extremely
eager to help each other
you have an extremely humble group of
individuals
who are all genuinely interested in
getting to know one another as people
because again the class size are small
provides an opportunity for you to have
tons of small group
dinners and drinks and study groups and
whatever you want to engage in you have
the opportunity to do so and everyone is
extremely forthcoming
in ensuring that you feel welcome both
the class above you as well as
your existing class so i think the thing
that that stands out to me most
is you have this incredibly talented
driven ambitious pool of people
that through some magic at admissions
the result is that these are all
individuals that
want to help one another and don't try
to put themselves above the other to the
point that
you're always really comfortable going
to classmates with ideas i mean
or just problems like especially during
summer internships even where a lot of
people are
kind of in new industries and trying out
new spaces there
in our class-wide slack channel there is
constant questions being posed to other
members of the class being like
how do i do x y or c associated with the
new industry they're working in whether
it be developing a new slide deck
or doing you know market map or market
research or basic questions about like
how
i don't know hybrid cars work anything
of the above you'll see these questions
constantly pose and constantly answered
so
excuse me nigel is asking
what questions did you ask yourself
before you decided the gsb was the right
place to you
for you and why don't we just broaden
that and if a couple of you would
talk about how you decided how did you
choose the gsb
over other choices that you might have
had
who wants to take that i'll i'll start
with that
it's one thing about the gsb that really
attracted me
was the small class size i loved that it
was small enough
where you could get to know everyone in
your class on a first name basis
but it was also a big enough class where
there's a ton of diversity and different
backgrounds that you can learn from
and i just loved that aspect about it
great anybody else how you decided on
the gsb
uh yeah i'll say something it's related
to the culture question
um that was answered earlier but um for
me culture was a really important part
of my decision making process
and the way i like to think of stanford
um
the way that i had heard of it and also
in which i experienced
was i think the culture in stanford
um really spoke to me in that it wasn't
just about becoming a better
business leader it was about becoming a
better human
um and that was really important to me
as i thought about if i'm gonna spend
two years
um dedicating you know my time to this
like
what where do i want to see growth is it
just in technical skills or is it also
in
like leadership skills and interpersonal
dynamics and that sort of thing and i
know
um i knew that stanford differentiated
itself in that way and so
that's why i chose stanford great uh
lauren this is a
uh okay this is a question specifically
for you from
cohen he asked how did you prepare
yourself financially to become a
full-time entrepreneur
and did you have any debt to manage
after the gsb
yes this has been a challenge for sure
but i'm so glad that i took the leap
into entrepreneurship
one thing i'll add to my story is that i
did
work for a private equity firm right
after graduating until
um earlier this year when i decided to
go full-time into entrepreneurship
and i have lived very frugally
saving as much money as i can while
um while i'm in this sort of building my
business
phase so it's it has been a lot to
manage but
i think with some advanced planning you
can
pay down some debt save your money
and get prepared for the period of time
in which
it takes to build an income back up
great this is a question from robert
who's asking can you discuss how
the role of the stanford network has
played in your post mba career
and i'm going to skew that specifically
to the south and southeast
in terms of you know folks who
went back uh after business school or
eventually ended up there
um uh how uh how the network helped you
in terms of your career search and um
why don't we start with you tamara since
you've um you know worked at a few
places there in the south since
graduation yeah and also i
um stayed in silicon valley uh
for several years after graduating so
i've just been i've just moved back to
the south a couple of years ago so
naturally the first thing i did when i
got here and a little bit before i
before i moved was to reach out to the
stanford network
and admittedly you know the southeast
has just
just by sheer volumes fewer alumni than
obviously you know in silicon valley
where you can find a lot of stanford
alums um so that that said
there's not you know like a ton of
stanford alums in
energy here um in the southeast
or um you know in insurance for that
matter but there are a few
um and when you reach out
um i actually i'm sure i've not received
a response from someone
but really i mean everyone that i've
reached out to as far as i can remember
has reached back out to me
either set up time to see me in person
or to set up a call
or offer to um you know introduce me to
someone else
and i think that that's that's really
special i've heard experiences
from other people who go to other
business schools that there's
that's just not the case i wouldn't say
that we feel obligated we just
genuinely you know like uh care for each
other in our careers like that
experience that francisco talked about
it kind of
last afterwards like i want to help you
you know in your career in your life you
know achieve and if i have some
piece of the puzzle that you need i'm
you know willing to help
and that was my experience so um
you know people helped get me interviews
they introduced me to people who could
answer
you know the more you know intensive
questions that they had
and also um you know they're two of my
really good friends that when i moved
here i had no friends
two of my really good friends now are
gsb alums
um they did we didn't go to school
together at the same time but i met them
and we really connected and
you know that's valuable too um just
having those friendships people to
you know be with you as you you know
challenge through
life um that's what i experienced at
school and what i've experienced
afterwards with the network
right anybody else want to comment on
career search or alumni network in terms
of um
uh going back to the south or
um i i'll just say that speaking as a
current
student and seeing how both my
classmates and i
like just abuse the alumni network by
bang them with requests and how 100 of
the time they
answer those requests uh or help us out
in whatever way they can
uh i the network is strong and
when i've heard other places maybe it's
not as strong or people aren't
responsive but
i truly one hundred percent of the time
i even an alum no matter what level
of of leader they are whether it be the
c-suite or
whatever they always always respond
uh here's a question from mary she's
asking how did your career goals
change as a result of the gsb and
did you prioritize time and energy
during school
to sort of figure out what what the next
steps were
so we would like to take that
did you all come in with the same career
goals as you ended up
uh going into post post gsb
uh i can take some of that i was
caught up in the pre-dot-com bubble of
startup land
um living in silicon valley and
really my big decision at the time was
to go to business school or not
because silicon valley was at its peak
the bubble was at its peak
and well i'd like to say i was really
smart in picking my timing when the
bubble burst
i was really lucky um and
for me i was thinking i'd go back to do
a small company
and what i found throughout my journey
is i like working with larger teams of
people
i like calling on and working with some
really large companies trying to do
really big and audacious things out in
the world
and trying to help them do that and for
me technology is certainly a catalyst to
drive
some of those changes so whereas i
thought i would go
smaller more entrepreneurial and took a
lot of
classes that way what i realized was
kind of what gave me more energy
personally and so
i did have goals but they kind of
changed as my thinking evolved
throughout my journey and that's part of
what i'd say the gsp is even after you
finish
is it is a journey and you embrace it
you accept it you lean into it
and you see where it takes you you know
believe it or not even though i've been
in the south for
14 years i don't have a really strong
accent i don't know if any of you
noticed that
still speak pretty fast and the reason i
moved to the south was
my wife's from atlanta she had gone to
vanderbilt and we agreed this would be a
great place to
have a family and for me at a certain
point in my career i decided it was more
important
to move to a place with good education
and a bigger house
and things like that and to do my career
from there
versus staying in a bigger urban
area where there's typically a lot more
fluidity in jobs and things like that
it was a personal choice trade-off but
it's been really rewarding because the
jobs i've had even when i came to
salesforce a while ago
uh they preferred me to be somewhere
else and you know being a good former
investment banker
and business school person i gave them a
price uh maybe not a rational price of
what it would take to move me to san
francisco or new york
uh and i priced it such that i could
still stay here in nashville
and for me i've engaged with people who
have graduated here as well as the
alumni network
and i still call on my network i
actually had a call last night with a
friend who's at a company
i won't say which one but they're being
bought by another company and we've got
a large partnership with his company not
he and i we didn't do the partnership
but there is a partnership between our
companies and really what i was calling
him to do was number one
check in on him and his daughters make
sure everything was going good he just
had a
birthday but then number two was just to
understand
how is the power shift right nothing
proprietary but
how are decisions being made they used
to be more centralized now they're very
decentralized
how is that really showing up because
that'll help me better
partner with them not around a specific
sale or anything like that but
really show up and so the network being
in the south
being connected to not only the local
community but the broader gsb community
has been absolutely invaluable to me and
it's been really fun
so a question from kayla is asking for
those of you that
came from a non-business background
before the gsb
uh what did you struggle in and i know
tamara you mentioned you
studied engineering i don't remember
everybody else's
undergrad well i know actually okay you
did study business but
for anybody who was non-business
background would you struggle in
i'll start i think the classes that i
struggled in the most
were um it certainly wasn't the
quantitative classes
um like at the gsb people get i think in
business school in general
people there's this like stigma on quant
classes you know quantitative classes
um you know the the economics classes
and
um probability and statistics like
um those kind of classes
for anyone with a science and
engineering background i so encourage
business school it's a great complement
to an engineering
degree especially obviously you want to
move into business
so the the quant classes you know you
learn a lot but it's a little bit of a
breeze it doesn't
you know compare to college level you
know kind of engineering um
the other classes that require more
like business intuition or experience
like i struggled in but that was you
know the biggest opportunity
for growth so you know even like a basic
strategy class like how to analyze an
opportunity
or um uh
so i'm thinking about like the first
year class in in
strategy or even like uh the global
markets class
where um you know we just understand
kind of business in different countries
that was you know it's just because it's
unfamiliar
but that's you know the the the biggest
growth for me
anybody else want to comment on uh what
you struggled in and actually
she's got another interesting question
of what did you do really well and
because she didn't have a business
background so
anybody want to comment on either of
those
um i came in from public policy and so
not really from a business background
per se and i didn't study business in
undergrad
um uh you know i think that
i i'm sure some of you a lot of you work
in finance but like i learned what irr
was eight months ago 12 months ago um
but you know i managed to get a job and
kind of real estate private equity this
summer and so it kind of shows you
how the school can get you from zero to
100 on
any number of issues in finance or
accounting or what have you so
for me finance was tough it was kind of
a hard learning curve but
the school is a good job of kind of
delineating you
on skill level or on kind of knowledge
base based on your previous industry
experience and then what you said in
undergrad
having done zero finance i was putting
obviously the lowest level which was
great for me
and again going from like not knowing
what
irr is to getting an investing job in
march after taking the real estate class
that
david mentioned earlier was was pretty
astounding to witness
i can add that too to my story i mean i
had no finance
experience in the first job i i got out
of school out of stanford was
mergers and acquisitions i mean it was
extremely heavy
uh finance and i said i struggled with
you know strategy classes
and business classes but i ended up
running a business so i mean
i couldn't agree i think that's a great
phrase you can get up to speed 0 to 100
with the with the curriculum and the
experiences of the gsb
and feel really confident doing it you
know like i can do this i can add value
to this organization francisco
referred to different levels in the
finance class and
in your required classes there are two
or sometimes three
different levels of you know
introductory
accelerated advance so for those
required courses you will be in
you know level the level that best
challenges
challenges you morgan is asking about
social impact anybody want to comment on
classes or projects or
that you did relating to social impact
anybody okay
um we do have a center for social
innovation
and we do actually have a certificate in
um
uh social entrepreneurship and um
and public management that uh that you
can pursue
um at the gsb uh
and there's a social entrepreneurship
club
and there's um some are internships
in in social impacts so if that's your
interest you will find a place
there's also a bunch of grant programs i
believe right for summer internships
say it again there's also like several
grant programs
right yep yep yep
actually surprising that i mean you've
got a panel of five of us that didn't do
social impact when i was at
at the gsb almost everybody i mean i
felt like was engaged there was just
like a huge
cohort of people who were there to do
um social impact and who have done like
amazing things afterwards in the area of
social investing
one cool experience is that there's some
formal program that puts
students on boards of um
social organizations while at the gsb so
to get that type of
board experience but really adding value
to a non-profit or a social organization
um is really amazing but there's tons of
coursework and you know
you'll definitely find your people you
know they're they're just
it's it's very popular at the gsp
great uh here's a question from um anand
uh what would you do differently if you
were to go back to the gsb again
um and actually i like the second part
of your question and on what is the most
important advice you would give to
prospective students so
let's answer that one and stephanie why
don't we start with you what's the most
important advice you would give to
prospective students
yeah sure um so i've been reflecting on
my gsb experience a lot i
just graduated a couple months ago and
so it's brushed my
mind and i wanted to make sure i like
processed um everything that happened
and as i think about something that
you know i might change if i were to go
back is
um just continuing to push myself out of
my comfort zone in terms
of you know the people i expose myself
to
i think um the gsb is such an incredible
melting pot with
such a diverse group of people but
i think all of us naturally just you
know gravitate towards people that are
like us or that make us feel comfortable
which obviously
there's nothing wrong with that and you
want to find your community and
everybody does
but i think something that i think i
would do
if i were to go back is um for the
people that
maybe i didn't naturally connect with
immediately like just pushing myself to
continue to um you know engage with them
learn more about
um different perspectives and groups and
that sort of thing
and the gsb has given has created um
different opportunities to do so that i
really appreciated but
um i think just on a personal level i
think that's something that
i would want to do better at moving
forward great
thank you um lk or david do you want to
comment on that
yeah i'd love to add some
advice that i would give prospective
students i think one of the most
important things
before going to business school is to
really know
why you're going and what you want to
get out of business school
when you're at the gsb there are 10
million
different things going on at any given
hour
and you're going to get pulled in so
many different directions
which can be a great thing if your goal
is to go explore
but i really urge you to take the time
before business school to ask yourself
what you want to get out of it
and that way you're not influenced when
you get there by what everyone else is
doing
for me the advice i would give people is
truly embrace the community
whether you're married and bring your
spouse to
the different events or your significant
other to the events or
you're not and you're out meeting
different people but truly embrace what
it has to offer i think stephanie said
it well which is
there's always those people who you're
in retrospect you're like
wow i wish i would have taken them to
lunch like just on a one-on-one to get
to know them better because
they've got such a unique background the
other thing
i would say is getting in there once
you're accepted you think you're pretty
good and then you get there and you're
blown away
by the people around you and you feel
really really inferior all of a sudden
and it seems to be somewhat common and
maybe part of the culture there
but lean into it go all in embrace your
classmates
share your insecurities and if i were to
do one thing
sooner i probably would have done that
sooner and
that would be my advice lean in uh
embrace the community and whatever it
has to offer
and with your own group but force
yourself
to go outside of your comfort zone in
your comfort group
to grab lunch or coffee or whatever with
any
with some person who you just haven't
spent any time with
and really you know what you'd need to
do to get them to go to lunch with you
you shoot them a note and you say i've
never spent time with you and that feels
odd
can we go have lunch right honestly like
that's all it takes
and it seems so trivial but we all get
so busy in every part of our life
to not make time for that and so i would
say make a little bit extra time for
connection
great we have a question from jared
about
coming to school with your significant
other or your family
so um francisco i know you uh
brought your spouse and tamara i think
you were at school with your
with your spouse so uh why don't we
start with the two of you
uh yeah coming to school with the spouse
um
is i mean it's it's it was great for us
um obviously yours your spouse or your
single other
has to you know sacrifice a lot to move
across the country
um as minded but um
you know she was able to get a job
within a couple of months actually at
salesforce
uh david so thanks um and
uh but but i i do know that
you know it's a tricky situation the
fact that you as a student are pulled in
a lot of different directions and it
takes
like a concerted effort to really make
sure that your spouse is well integrated
your signature
is well integrated uh to the community
otherwise it kind of feels like you're
living two different lives
one when you go home and then one when
you're at school and so the more that
you can work really early on to make
sure that your significant other
is well integrated and well introduced
with all of your new friends and
connections the easier it will be
for you to kind of merge those together
otherwise i think people have trouble
kind of navigating doing both having a
home life and a
school life that are separate when
gsp takes over all aspects of your life
and so you need to make sure that that
you put in the effort and
you're seeing the others in the effort
to make it a successful transition
yeah i would say i mean i have friends
at business schools who went to business
schools all over the country
it's it's challenging no matter where
you go to school
um you know you just want to spend so
much time with your classmates
fully drinking in all of the opportunity
constantly networking and socializing
and it's really very fun and there's a
lot of stuff that you can bring your
spouse to and then a lot of stuff that
it's really just for the gsb community
so um
we found it to be challenging i think
knowing that ahead of time no matter
where you go to
school is really valuable because you
can start to
like you know you you don't get
blindsided like you know exactly what
this experience is going to be like and
you need to
i mean it's just like anything else even
as a leader like you need to set
expectations for what this is going to
be like
um you know that i'm going to be
spending a lot of time with my
classmates that i'm going
um you know most evenings to not be
home until really late or um you know
this week i've got to really buckle down
and prepare for my exams or whatever it
is
the communication is definitely the key
um
i i agree with francisco to the extent
that you can integrate your spouse into
the gsb community it makes it a lot
easier
i found that i actually had to invest a
lot of time
in a community outside of the gsb so my
husband and i joined a church
we had a whole group of friends that
were like our mutual
friends outside of the gsb i mean
the silicon valley is just amazing you
can network with people in a variety of
industries
you can also like find friendships there
too they're just
you know amazing people in northern
california and so
um you know but i didn't have a lot of
time to spend with those friends but i i
needed to make sure that he
felt plugged into a community
so he would be okay while i was doing
this thing for two years and
it's only two years and then it's over
and uh
you kind of you know like recover i mean
the one thing i will say about you know
for anybody who
is interested in getting a spouse or
already in a relationship
i mean the transformation that i
experienced at the gsb didn't help me
not
not only helped me become a better
leader it helped me become a better
spouse
more vulnerable more communicative more
willing to admit my imperfections and
insecurities and
you know my husband is you know he'll
he'll he'll
you know definitely share that with
people like i became a different person
someone better
but please join me in thanking all of
our panelists for sharing their insights
and experiences with you today